sales sales sales sales sales sales
sales sales sales sales
and for like an entrepreneur not a sales
person how about just an entrepreneur
who's looking to start a business well
if you can't sell
if you can't influence if you can't
persuade good luck trying to get your
business off the ground i'm not talking
about just your customers i'm talking
about the bankers the people of venture
capitalists your vendors your credit
card processor the people who work for
you how do you get people to work for
you excited how do you get them excited
how do you get them to want to buy into
your vision
at the highest level what sales really
is it's the transference of emotion
and the emotion you're transferring is
this emotion of certainty that someone
feel certain yeah it's a good thing it's
going to help me it's going to fill my
need when you're an entrepreneur you're
trying to start a business and you're
recruiting people well you're selling
people on your vision
for the future your vision for this
company if you can't do that good luck
trying to get great people to work for
you it's very it's almost it's nearly
impossible which is why you always see
you know the people they say oh he's a
visionary well that's true but typically
not only are they visionaries they also
possess the ability to sell
the vision
to other people to inspire them to
motivate them so selling is not just
like you know people think of selling oh
well i'm not a salesman i don't even
well yes you do you need to learn how to
influence how about trying to get your
kids to make their bed or do their
homework or believe in the value of
education
how about trying to get a landlord to
give you a reduction on your rent or to
extend the lease the way you want how
about trying to negotiate terms you
understand it cuts to everything
you need to be able to sell whether it's
kickstarter whether it's new york times
whether it's your local newspaper you
need to be able to communicate
effectively and sell which is why when
entrepreneurs ask me for books
to read outside of business books i say
on writing well
bird by bird all books on writing
improving communication
david ogilvy ogilvian advertising
study print ads where you have very
little space
i think those are all very very
effective the best entrepreneurs i've
ever met are all good communicators
it's the one
perhaps one of the very few unifying
factors they're exceptional
communicators practice is the only way
to get better at communicating and
practicing speaking does not provide you
generally with something to review later
which is why the written word is so
powerful
writing is thought crystallized on a
piece of paper that can then be reviewed
it's very difficult to do that with
speech which is why i recommend people
focus on honing their skills in writing
and
take time to study good direct response
ads
take time to
for instance maybe develop a swipe file
so one of the things that i did for
years is anytime i bought something
i would identify
the ad
the phone call
the print ad the the offer whatever it
was
that made me decide to buy it and i
would either cut it out or record it put
it into evernote whatever it might be
and save it so i had a record of
everything that i bought and why i
bought it
and then i could go back and review it
and i'd be like oh
looks like i fell for this this and this
not a bad way it looks like this tipped
me from
or
not interested to yeah i'll spend five
fifty five hundred five thousand dollars
on that yeah i save all that
everything that works in sales has been
done already you do not need to reinvent
the wheel so just keep track of the crap
that you buy or the awesome stuff that
you buy and decide
you know what was the trigger what
pushed me over the edge and then just
sell to people like you that's what i do
it's really easy people are like who's
your market i'm like well
you know i'm a 30-something sf based
tech savvy mail so why don't i just sell
those people
it makes it a lot easier than trying to
guess austin i think you need to reverse
engineer who you're selling to so if i
were you austin i would spend all of
january
taking people out to lunch and dinner or
drink or getting them on the phone
but literally spending the entire month
of january not selling to people and
just listening to the people that you
sell to to figure out what their pain
points are i would walk in and be like
hey drock you know i sell you computer
stuff and things that nature what are
your pain points what's your problem
what's your struggles in your business
like let's let's cut the crap like yes i
want to sell to you but let's take a
step back i want to sell to you by
providing you some sort of value maybe i
have a friend maybe i will recommend
that you watch the askgaryvee show to
make your business better maybe i'll do
a lot of things but what i'm doing is
i'm providing you value and our
conversation and our relationship is not
just predicated on
on me selling you know it's kind of like
i was talking to one of my friends he's
like i want to have better relationships
with girls i'm like cool why don't you
make it something about other than sex
like if your whole relationship is like
i want to hang out with you every time
to just hook up
there's probably a good chance that
person doesn't think that you're
providing them much value outside of
that execution which is a fine execution
everybody needs it i get it blah blah
blah
same way i think about sales if you're
just selling every single time that is
what your foundational relationship is
based on and you become spam and sales
all the time why don't you spend all of
january not selling ever once and
opening your ears and listening and
trying to help even outside of the
context of you
even out of the outside the context of
you meaning how can you help them
besides just their business maybe you'll
get to know drock and find out that his
aunt is a huge dallas cowboys fan and
you just get a dallas cowboys hat and
say hey you go to ebay and buy a you
know a tony door set opened starting
lineup for 49 cents three dollars
shipping but you send and say hey give
this to your aunt it's not what you
spent it was the thought that stuff
matters top salespeople commit
themselves to lifelong learning this by
the way changed my life so dramatically
when i was 24 almost like i tripped over
something and picked myself up and it
was a great treasure and the treasure
was that your mind is your most precious
asset and the quality of your thinking
determines the quality of your sales
career
if you commit yourself to lifelong
learning
you must achieve such extraordinary
success and i cannot emphasize this too
often
read listen to audio programs attend
seminars and never forget that the most
valuable asset you will ever have is
your mind as you continue to learn
you'll eventually become one of the most
valuable sales people in your company
the more knowledge you acquire that can
be applied to practical purposes the
greater will be your rewards and the
more you will be paid to see the clouds
this is about rain making about sales
these are the things i learned about
sales first thing is
let 100 flowers blossom this i stole
from chairman mao although it's not
clear to me he implemented letting 100
flowers blossom
100 flowers blossoms means that at the
start of a company you'll often see your
people who are not your intended
customers using your product or service
and they're going to be using it in ways
you didn't anticipate many entrepreneurs
go crazy my god the wrong people are
buying our products in large quantities
what are we doing wrong let's get
marketing and sales in here we need to
reposition the product because we know
who should buy our product
well it's categorically stupid
fundamentally when you see this
happening first of all take the money
take the money
there's two theories in engineering for
revising a product one is you go to the
people who aren't buying your product
and you ask them why aren't you buying
our macintosh mr fortune 500 cio
and the cio will say
you don't have a letter quality printer
driver you don't have lotus one two
three
you come back to the lab you convince
lotus to do it you get a letter quality
printer driver you go back to the
fortune 500 cio you say all right we
listened now there's a printer driver
now there's one two three they still
won't buy it they still won't buy it the
other theory in engineering is you go to
the people who are buying your product
mr desktop publishing or miss desktop
publishing why are you buying our
product because it's wysiwyg because
it's high resolution printing so you
come back to the labs and you say wow
people are buying our product to use for
desktop publishing not spreadsheet
database and word processing like we
intended and what do they need for
desktop publishing system they need
bigger monitors they need higher
resolution printers they need higher
resolution monitors they need all these
things to make desktop publishing better
that's my theory fix for who's buying
ignore the people who are atheists
atheists are too hard to convert to your
religion go for agnostics and go for
believers forget the atheists second
point is you need to enable people to
test drive your product
that you're saying to them i think
you're smart and because i think you're
smart i'm not going to bludgeon you into
becoming my customer
take home my product take home my
service try my software try my website
then you decide the third point is to
suck down
one of the fundamental shortcomings of
sales training is that you think or many
people think
that selling a new product is about
sucking up you need to suck up to cxo
level people suck up to a cio suck up
the cto suck up to a ceo a cmo sucking
up the cxo level people
it has been my experience that
particularly from a tech startup
the people who truly make the decision
to try a product or service are not the
people with cxo
vice president or director level title
they are the people who are
administrative aids and database
administrators and tech support people
they're the interns they're the summer
hires they're people without titles
they're the people who really do the
work however and so if you want to be
successful in sales you have to
understand something that in most
organizations the higher you go the
thinner the oxygen and therefore the
more difficult it is to find intelligent
life right
so
if you dedicate yourself in a sales
effort to sucking up you'll be sucking
up to the dumbest people in the
organization
you need to learn to suck down and you
need to learn to suck across
because that's where the decisions are
made for a high-tech startup suck down
suck across don't just suck up and this
is the one where everyone goes uh i
don't want to be a sales person right uh
one of the things that we do in our
business is we take
experts and we teach them how to package
their information up into products like
ebooks and other information products
and sell them
well when i start talking to these
experts almost universally they say
things like
i've got all the content i just need to
find someone who can market and sell it
for me
and when i say to them well you know
what would probably be good for you is
to actually learn some marketing in
sales they go
oh
i don't want to learn i'm not a salesman
they kind of like look down at sales
people like it's some like lower form of
human business scum or something like
that
and uh
you know you imagine okay i have to put
on a funky like a weird suit and like a
windbreaker like a car salesman in order
to sell my product i would never want to
do that
well
when you really learn sales as i know
you know because you're very you're a
fantastic sales person that the best
selling methods
are consultative selling where you don't
sit down and try to talk someone into
buying you sit down and you say let me
ask you some questions let me learn
about you and find out what all your
problems are and let me see if what i
have is even a fit
and then once you've found out where
they're at what their problems are what
all the challenges they're facing or and
what they'd like to accomplish then you
sell solutions you sell
them fixing their problems you sell them
getting what they want
not your thing
and the best of the best of the best
sales people are the ones that walk in
and sit down and ask a bunch of
questions and then say
my product can't help you let me refer
to some you know refer you to someone
who can because those are the people
that win the trust
and that when they say this is the thing
that will solve your problem the
prospect says
that's the thing i need because they're
trustworthy so learning consultative
selling and really learning how to sell
like a professional is very important do
not try to sell something
that you wouldn't buy yourself
okay so if you don't truly think it's
something that you would yourself be a
customer of don't try to pitch it you
know don't be a used car salesman so
please make sure that whatever you're
trying to come up with is compelling
enough that you would yourself deeply be
deeply interested in buying that product
i spent 17 years getting a formal
education competition's good
competition's healthy for who
imagine if you were the only marketing
company in the world
is that better than having millions of
marketing companies
exactly
i want to own the sector i want to own
the sector i want somebody when somebody
thinks about sales training i want them
to equate
grant cardone
and whatever i have to spend to get
there i'll spend to get there i want to
own the sector completely i don't want
to compete in it so one way you could
own a sector is by tweeting okay if
you're not tweeting or facebooking or
youtubing okay or
using linkedin if you aren't using these
free mediums to communicate to the world
you're not in the game man you're not in
the game
okay now this morning if you look at my
twitter account today
because this is more than just about
selling and closing a transaction if i
don't have anybody to pay attention to
me i can't sell our clothes would you
agree
look there's nobody here man hey man i'm
a good salesman i can shut you down
right now who am i talking to myself
i need people
obscurity obscurity is the biggest
problem your business has there is no
bigger problem than obscurity it's not
money it's not financing it's not price
it's not value it's not packaged
it is one thing
obscurity all those media programs that
you saw me on this morning they all tell
you that there's not enough money the
banks aren't loaning consumers don't
have confidence people aren't healthy
the economy is in trouble dude none of
those are the problem the problem is
nobody knows you
i don't know you man i don't know you
who are you
right
price doesn't matter at this point value
doesn't matter at this point the package
the offer
the problems i don't know you
if you don't know me you can't buy my
books
obscurity is a bigger problem than money
okay so i'll go broke
just trying to get out of obscurity and
i'm gonna use these free mediums
to do so they did a study at harvard of
the the different levels of
sales techniques that were the most in
top sales guys in the world and women
used versus those that were average they
went through several steps about getting
rapport about understanding the client's
needs you know about you know being able
to uh demonstrate that the features and
benefits the products and and going
through overcoming objections and then
closing the sale
and yeah they looked at it and what was
surprising was that the people who were
the absolute cream of the cream the top
1 of the top 1 of sales people on the
planet
did exactly the same steps
as those who were average
the difference was that
those that were exceptional
focused on the first part which is
being able to build rapport being able
to understand the client's needs
in other words there was a sincere level
of appreciation for what the client
wanted the intention that was set the
congruency that was set was how can i
serve you how can i understand you not
how can i sell to you in other words how
can i contribute rather than how can i
take
now here's what's interesting
the people that focused more on that
spent far less time on the closing and
overcoming objections it was almost a
natural progression of the sale
those that spent less time on building
rapport and understanding the client's
needs and creating the relationship of
trust based upon a level of sincerity
appreciation and authenticity of who
they were
those
that you know spent less time on that
and got through to the sale and or got
through to trying to close the sale had
to spend more time on overcoming
objections
and closing techniques
to make up for a lack
of authentic connection and wanting to
add value to the clients that make sense
you don't have to learn better closing
techniques unless you focus on being
less than authentic about adding value
to the client hello
so going on sales training
is usually a
substitute and a poor substitute
for coming to the table from a place
where you say you know something i am
willing
to let this sale go if i sincerely and
every core of my being every cell in my
body vibrates the fact that this really
isn't the best product or you know type
of of deal for the client if you can
come to the table from that place rather
than be hooked on the fact that your
manager has given you a sales target and
you need to make you know
a close this friday
then
by
contrast by you know paradox
your sales tend to go up
you spend less time prospecting because
these people that you do connect with
have such a level of trust
and appreciation for what you've done
and how you work with them
they're far more likely to recommend you
so your referral bank starts building
now yeah if you can come from a place of
authenticity and sincerity i guarantee
you you spend time there not just your
clients not just your prospects not just
your your potential sales
will start to increase but the richness
of who you are
comes out and that's in your
relationship with your spouse your
relationship with your kids your
relationship with with everybody
people want to do business with you
rather than people are being convinced
to do business with you make sense
go out this week and try that go out
this week and say you know something
before i walk into that meeting i'm
gonna sit there for a minute or two and
just connect
and think you know
i is my intention pure am i going to
come from a place of adding value and if
i walk into that meeting understanding
that yeah this has to match this
how am i going to show up differently
and i think you might be surprised what
happens
now of course ladies and gentlemen
everything is selling and everybody is a
sales person
whether you're a dentist a doctor a
preacher a teacher a coach a child uh
music matters doesn't make any
difference what it is that you do
everybody is a salesperson let me share
a couple of examples with you of what
i'm talking about when i was between the
11th and 12th grades
during world war ii
i went to junior college so i could pick
up some extra classes so i could get in
the naval air corps all right now i had
to pick up an extra course in history in
order to graduate and so i would be free
then the following my senior year to
take a lot of extra math and science
well i didn't want to take american
history what possible good is it going
to do me
you know to learn something that
happened 100 years ago or 200 years ago
but i had to learn it so i was going to
go in there and i was at least going to
pass but don't think i'm going to try to
remember it i'll just transfer the
knowledge from the teacher to my mind to
the pad and then i'll get out of there
and they'll end it
but the teacher threw me a curve he was
coached joby harris at hinds junior
college in jackson mississippi and
you're talking about a salesman folks he
was a salesman he spent that entire
first period selling me on why i had to
learn
my history he really put the story on me
he also sold me that as an individual if
i had any ability that permitted me to
do more than support my family that i
had a moral obligation to my fellow
human being and my community
to donate some of my services for the
betterment of mankind
i walked out of that classroom that day
a history major
only subject i made consistent days in
throughout the time i was in college
what i do today in all of the activities
outside of my
actual business was directly
emphatically influenced by that salesman
a school teacher coach joby harris
everything is selling i'll never forget
when our second daughter was born our
first child was three years old at the
time
and i've been out on the road not long
after our baby uh bro came home from the
hospital i've been out on the road and i
got stuck there was a snow storm and i
spent the night in a greyhound bus
fortunately on the side of the road when
i got in the next morning i was
exhausted there was about 10 inches of
snow on the ground and i'd know sooner
walked in and just had my top coat and
my gloves and my head off when the
redhead said to me well honey uh we got
to go to the store we got we need some
things so i reluctantly put all the gear
back on and my three-year-old said daddy
i want to go and i said oh susie i said
the weather's too bad it's too cold and
wet and uh i won't be gone long but she
said daddy i'll be so lonely
i said oh susie you won't be lonely i
said your mother's here the mage here
your baby sister is here i said you
won't be lonely she looked right at me
and she said but daddy i'll be lonely
for you
[Music]
i don't need to tell you she went to the
store with me
you see
the truth of the matter is the truth of
the matter is everything is selling the
third example at our church we recently
got a new music minister now please
understand
that i've got the kind of voice that uh
prompted mitch miller to write me a
personal letter asking me not even to
bother to sing along with and you know i
want you to understand it my own
children ask that i not sing in church
but last sunday was our first sunday and
this minister had the congregation so
excited he sold him so much on
participating now he knows his music too
but he had a so gung-ho that for the
first time in my life i actually
enthusiastically got involved in the
singing process
everything ladies and gentlemen is
selling i mean everything is selling and
that's one of the reasons that i'm so
excited about it thank you guys so much
for watching i'd love to know which of
the videos resonated the most with you
leave it in the comments below i'd also
love to know
either what your biggest sales challenge
is right now or what your biggest sales
advice would be
or both leave in the comments below i'm
gonna join in the discussion thank you
so much for watching continue to believe
and i'll see you soon
you